Speaker 1: All right. Let's keep going today. So
much to to pack into today's program. We're not
going to spend a lot of time on this. Last night,
not only did Sean HANNITY go after me and direct
the right wing contrived hate mob against me,
he also aired another portion of his interview
with the failed former President Donald Trump.
And this is this is a short clip. It's really
just the epitome of what I've been telling you for
years. Trump loves dictators. Trump is impressed
by dictators. Trump thinks dictators are big,
strong guys and the entire thing. And Sean HANNITY
did this thing, which I mean, it's just a complete
and total backfire. It's really unbelievable where
he lists different dictators and authoritarians to
Trump and says, Tell me the first thing that comes
to mind. And with every single one of them, what
comes to mind is how great Trump gets along with
them. It's, you know, if seven years ago I had
told you we're going to have a former president
who, when asked about dictators and authoritarian
strongmen, just because I got along really well,
I don't know, got along really well. I don't
know. You wouldn't have believed it. But that's
where we are. Look at this orange nightmare.
Speaker 2: Right. And give me the names and
give me quick, just short sentence narratives.
Speaker 1: By the way, Trump just so sweaty,
eyes, almost swollen, shut, never clear.
Why? What? Why is it so hard? I don't know.
Speaker 2: What comes to your mind. Putin
Well, I'm going to have to go a little short,
but I got along with him great. Had I been
president, he would have been much better
off because he wouldn't have gone into Ukraine.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The reason, by the way, this
entire thing, they keep repeating it. What why did
Putin wait for Joe Biden to go into Ukraine? Putin
had every reason to think that he wouldn't have to
invade in order to get more territory with Trump
as president. If Trump gets another four years,
Putin can probably get away with taking more land
in other ways that doesn't require what he is now
doing. It's such a laughable talking point. Okay,
so there's Putin. We're going to keep going.
Speaker 2: But ultimately he's going to take
over all of Ukraine.
Speaker 1: We know,
right? Especially if you ever say.
Speaker 2: To a man, I got along again,
I got along with him great until I came in,
we would have been able to work together
very well. I got I made an unbelievable
deal for our farmers and manufacturers where
China was giving us $50 billion a year to
our farmers. And our manufacturing.
Speaker 1: Got along great with Xi.
Speaker 2: Jinping.
Speaker 1: Sorry,
and I stepped over that, he says.
Speaker 2: Kim Jong un because $50
billion a year to our farmers and our
manufacturing. Young And again, you get
along with them. Great People don't want to
hear that. A lot of people say that's terrible
to get along with him. Great. When somebody has
nuclear weapons that can blow up the world, it's
nice to get along. I get along with him. Great.
Speaker 1: So, listen, there are two sides to
this, okay? Let me I really want to be this is
such a microcosm of the entire Trump fiasco on
foreign policy that we have to do both sides.
There is the simple side. The simple side is
Trump is impressed by authoritarians.
It's not just Putin and Xi and Kim Jong un
who he believes everything they say. And, you
know, we'll get to that. It's also Erdogan,
it's Orban, it's Bolsonaro, it's okay. It's all
of them. Part of it is Trump is just impressed
with them constitutionally, just who they are,
what they represent, how they behave. Trump is,
in some cases jealous of them that they have
Trump perceives them to have a gravitas that
he doesn't have but would like to. So there's that
side of it. But there's another side of it that's
important as well. It's easy to get along with
people who don't see you as a threat in any way.
Most of those leaders saw Trump for the bumbling
buffoon that he was. And when you're seen that
way, there is no reason to have conflict or a
tense relationship or disagreements or whatever
the case may be, because they don't take you
seriously enough to see you as a threat. You're
not credible enough, you're not alpha enough to
use their version of what they are talking about.
Why would you have trouble getting along with
someone who sees you as a doofus? You wouldn't.
And that's the other side of it. Now we can
apply this really specifically, for example,
with Kim Jong un. Going back decades. In
general. It's not that the North Korean
leader wasn't willing to meet with an American
president. It's that the American presidents
didn't see the point of meeting with the North
Korean leaders without some preconditions. Why?
When you consider the status difference between
an American president and a North Korean dictator
that leads the country. The North Korean dictator
is always willing to get the photo op to get the
propaganda value of meeting with an American
president to then show their population, Look,
we're on the world stage and we told that
president and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's not difficult to get a meeting with a North
Korean leader if you're an American. President
Trump was so clueless that when he convinced Kim
Jong un to meet with them, he acted like it was
an accomplishment. This is why he gets along with
these dictators, because they see Trump, they go,
Wow, this guy doesn't even understand why it is
that normally they wouldn't even meet with me. At
the meeting, Kim Jong un made the same promises
to Trump that every North Korean leader has
made in the past. Two American presidents,
which they have no intentions of keeping,
will demilitarize this and will do that and
will provide this other thing. Trump doesn't
know anything. So Trump thinks, Look at all of
these great promises I got. These are the same
promises that they've been making for decades.
They will do 10% of it in order to get food
aid and then ignore the other 90%. It's not an
accomplishment. So, again, it's easy to get along
with people who are just walking all over you in
every way because you're so clueless. But anyways,
so the whole point of it is a very sweaty,
very swollen Trump in this interview able
to say nothing other than I got along with
these guys really well. Of course you did.